tu avais j'en suis con c'est le cheval
de bataille de manuel valls
depuis des attentats de janvier contre
charlie hebdo et le supermarché cacher
le premier ministre français a fait de
la lutte au terrorisme sa priorité
absolue par exemple du coup fait
rarissime il a tenu à venir présenter
lui-même devant l'assemblée nationale un
nouveau projet de loi sur la
surveillance la menace terroriste est
aujourd'hui le défi le plus redoutable
un défi auquel nous devrons faire face
pendant longtemps il ne s'agit pas de
faire peur mais d'être lucide et de le
dire aussi clairement à nos compatriotes
la nouvelle loi donne beaucoup plus de
pouvoir aux services de renseignements
elle permettra une surveillance plus
étroite d'internet et facilitera les
côtes électronique des dispositions
nécessaires selon le premier ministre
devant la menace nouvelle à laquelle la
france est confrontée celle de l'ennemi
intérieur
les 1700 france et membre de filières
jihadistes les services de renseignement
ont établi que sept de ces individus le
parle du français ou de résidents en
france sont morts en actions suicides en
syrie ou en irak parmi eux six étaient
des nouveaux convertis
la loi ne fait pas l'unanimité des
opposants ont manifesté devant
l'assemblée nationale en matinée pour le
rappeler il dénonce une loi liberticide
impétueux attacked à la française les
technologies de surveillance qui vont
être utilisés sont massives et globale
c'est à dire que on a des outils qui
vont non seulement surveiller des
personnes suspectes mais tout leur
entourage est également les
intermédiaires volontaire ou non dit la
loi nous demandons aux parlementaires de
préciser le texte mais de limiter le
champ
de couverture de la surveillance de
limiter les moyens de surveillance pour
éviter qu'on surveille tout le monde
n'importe comment le vote sur le projet
de loi n'aura lieu qu'en mai prochain
mais son adoption ne fait d'ores et déjà
aucun doute car l'opposition de droite
soutient texte même s'il ne va cge pas
assez loin et selon un récent sondage
les deux tiers des français se disent
d'accord pour limiter les libertés sur
internet si c'est pour mieux lutter
contre le terrorisme
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
paris